I'm joined today by Richard Cahan who is
author of unamerican the incarceration
of Japanese Americans during World War
two there's so much Richard to talk
about with japanese-american internment
during World War two in relation to 2016
and 2017 but before we do that give us
the quick sort of summary of what this
interment incarceration was I actually
did one of the things you talked about
in the book which is the use of some of
these words that that are confusing
words of incarceration of Japanese
Americans during World War two for
people who don't know what happened
let's start there great well the
incarceration really began on pearl
harbor day with in 11 weeks of Pearl
Harbor over a hundred and ten thousand
japanese-americans were picked up from
their homes and forcibly removed the
worry was that they were going to either
collaborate or spy for for the
Government of Japan and the idea was if
we could put them in what turned out to
be concentration camps the security risk
would be lessened quite a bit it began
in late februari with executive order
9066 when President Franklin Roosevelt
passed an order that basically allowed
the military to decide the fate of
japanese-americans there was a lot of
consternation there wasn't a lot of
formal protests japanese-americans
pretty much saw that this was their
contribution to the war effort and I
think culturally standing up and
standing against government officials
was something that was unheard of
unusual at the time most of them were
kept for the duration of the war for
over three years some were released
during these three years they could move
to the midwest but most of them couldn't
do that because they didn't have
connections to the midwest so most of
them stayed when they were picked up
there was no idea whether they would be
picked up for a week a month a year
forever and so it's a very shameful part
of American history 60,000 of the
110,000 or close to 70,000 were actually
US citizens people that were born in the
United States and that's why the term in
in in tournament which has been used for
so many decades is now look down upon
because you and I American citizens
can't be interned uh so it's really a
it's a lie of what happens that's why we
use the word incarceration on the cover
of our book and the title and also
throughout the book we we mustn't I'm
have this sort of thought in our minds
that Americans today would never allow
this to happen to our neighbors or
people that our fellow citizens here in
the United States but back during world
war two what was the response of
neighbors to what was going on with
japanese-americans I look carefully at
that question I wish the news was better
um were a few letters to the editor
there was one organization the American
Friends Service Committee the bikers
that that stood up for the
japanese-americans but generally there
was this feeling that this was the best
interest in this country this was really
a story of when security triumphs over
civil liberties and when there were many
individual instances of American
neighbors helping whenever we heard
those stories we included them in the
book people who took over farms and gave
back the farms to families after the war
people who watched over possessions but
I wish there were more those stories
there there fortunately weren't enough
of them let's relate what we're talking
about here in terms of
japanese-americans during World War two
to what we have seen hints of under the
incoming Donald Trump administration and
and the the one policy idea that comes
to mind for me is this idea floated
about a Muslim registry that would exist
uh let's start more generally I mean
what is it right to see an overlap in
terms of at least the ideologies that
create these ideas well that's a
thousand-dollar question predicting the
future is so difficult but I will say a
couple things number one this is not
ancient history this happened 75 years
ago that many of the people who live
through this are still alive so we're
not talking
about the Greeks or the Civil War
something very far away these are
actually people who live in contemporary
days there are people who doubt that
something like this could happen but but
the problem is is even the discussion of
the Muslim registry brings this up it's
been said that it say that the
incarceration is a precedent the
American to the idea of the Muslim
registry look at this book look at the
records and you'll see it's a very bad
precedent to that once you start
separating American citizens and saying
you people are going to register and you
people don't have to register that's
when all the machinery begins it's
exactly what happened to Japanese
Americans they were first told they
should register and then within a couple
days they were told to report once the
registration process is started the
entire process is started so I think we
have to be very leery of what's going on
now is your sense that civil rights
organizations are better equipped today
than they were during World War Two to
prevent as you say the first steps from
starting the ACLU has been receiving
record donations uh we've seen a number
of these organizations really really be
emboldened by the election of Donald
Trump is that may be a good sign that we
have more safeguards in place I think it
is a good sign but um it's hard to fight
government when government has decided
there's are even talk of that that the
registry is constitutional it's
interesting that as I did my research I
looked at the early years of 1942 when
the when the terminal was being thought
of the same exact words were used that
this is constitutional I don't know how
people get to that you know that this is
Constitution this is a denial of civil
liberties and but but the same words are
starting to be used again in a in a it's
very early in I mean the administration
hasn't even begun yet and there are
people talking about this so I'd like to
say that we're more sophisticated more
determined more set up to stop things
like that but I've seen in the past what
happens when people get scared
you know when we get scared uh we make
very irrational decisions we make lots
of mistakes and I see people being
scared now and um that's worrisome but
not not that I'm someone to point to
things that the late Antonin Scalia ever
said as sort of guiding principles or
anything like that but I found it
interesting in preparing for a
conversation that Antonin Scalia the
conservative Supreme Court justice uh
who seat remains open on the Supreme
Court by the way said a couple of years
ago that quote you were kidding yourself
if you think the same thing referring to
incarceration camps will not happen
again even even he believing that it is
possible that circumstances in America
could lead to that again and I I think
maybe not that he's someone who's Tikku
whose morality and principles I follow
but if even Antonin Scalia recognize
that this could happen again I think
that that means a lot I I agree with you
he made the point a few years ago to law
students in Hawaii and and I agree the
fact that he is of a then that he would
then he would recognize this i think
it's it's very it's very worth noting
and i think that this book to me was a
surprise and then i saw how fast
everything happened and and it's still a
surprise to me how we tend not to look
back at these years and recognize them
there's i just spent the weekend in
arizona there was to incarceration camps
in arizona and to find these camps to
find the remains of these camps I
thought you can find anything on the
internet and one of the camps it was
absolutely impossible to find I had to
be guided by Native Americans that they
believe it or not the camps were on
Indian reservations and Native Americans
had to show me where these camps were so
there's a lot to learn from this
incident and from the book here what I
think you see here there's been many
great books written on the incarceration
novels and nonfiction but this book
shows photographs it really takes us
back to the time you can see what people
look like the day they were picked up
and you can see the conditions in the
camps when they were taken and I think
that helps
understand it helped me understand the
situation much better yeah the
photographs absolutely did disturbing
and illuminating in so many ways we've
been talking about the book unamerican
the incarceration of Japanese Americans
during World War two the book's author
is Richard Cahan it's been so great
speaking to you about this thank you so
much David I appreciate